und willkommen zu einem anderen thema
die linksfraktion hat zwei anträge
eingereicht in denen wird es um die
arbeitsbedingungen in der pflege und da
hören wir gleich rein was hat ihn dazu
sagt
es sind bücher geschrieben worden dass
schwarz ins krankenhaus ist erschienen
menschen wie recaro lange und franziska
bühler haben die skandale aufgeschrieben
unter welchen unmenschlichen bedingungen
sie arbeiten müssen die gefühle der
pflegekräfte aufgezeichnet was sie
empfinden wenn sie trotz ihrem
übermenschlichen einsatz abends nicht
einschlafen können weil sie die fehler
bei sich suchen und das sind noch nicht
einmal alle geschichten sehr geehrte
damen und herren letzte woche die
streiks in den unikliniken nr in nrw
hatten gerade begonnen mit einer gruppe
in köln zu einem vertraulichen gespräch
ein weil sie die schlimmsten geschichten
nicht in der öffentlichkeit erzählen
wollen liebe pflegekräfte sind natürlich
nicht eure fehler es sind nicht die
fehler der beschäftigten es ist das
system das hier in diesem hohen hause
nicht nur zugelassen sollen jahrelang
erbaut und erschaffen wurde es sind die
verantwortlichen in den regierungen die
alles längst wissen und zu lange nichts
getan haben so dass es zu solchen
zuständen kommen konnte sage er damen
und herren
oder soll es doch es trifft neben den
beschäftigten die schwächsten der
gesellschaft er trifft im wahrsten sinne
die alten und kranken die menschen in
den pflegeheimen und in den
krankenhäusern weil das
gesundheitssystem so am ende ist sie
sterben sie sichten vor sich hin und das
in einem reich in einem der reichsten
länder der welt daher heißt es nun
endlich handeln lasst uns in zwölfter
mai
2022 den tag der pflegenden nicht als
weiteren klatsch dank und verschiebe tag
beginnen soll lacht uns an diesem tag
den startpunkt setzen für grundlegende
änderungen im pflegebereich
die linke anträge eingereicht die die
grundlegenden probleme in der pflege
angehen ich bitte sie beugen sie sich
dem druck der uns aus den pflegt die
kliniken und pflegeheimen erreicht der
auch heute wieder auf die straße
getragen wird lasst uns das ändern
in der krankenhauspflege geht es um
entlastungen es gibt ein fertiges
instrument das nur auf seine umsetzung
wartet die pflegepersonal regelung 2.0
verpflichtende regelungen zur
personalbemessung in allen kliniken auch
das gilt als übergangslösung aber
zumindest das muss doch letztendlich
passieren nur so kommen wir zu einer
entlastung nicht nur für eine entlastung
sondern auch zu mehr pflegekräften denn
viele würden zurückkehren viele würden
wieder in vollzeit geben wenn der stress
nicht mehr so groß wäre erst letzte
woche erschienen dafür zu einer studie
wir müssen uns doch vor ja aber lesen
lesen alleine reicht nicht für die
verbesserung wir müssen uns das
vorstellen ich war in 46 uniklinik
standorte in nrw die gegenwärtig für
entlastung streiken da geht es nicht um
mehr geld da geht es einfach nur darum
dass mehr kolleginnen und kollegen
eingestellt werden und dennoch kämpft
der arbeitgeber mit übelsten methoden
obwohl es absolut notwendig für die
patientensicherheit ist
ausbildungskräfte werden bedroht die
sich am streik beteiligen wollen
kolleginnen die gerade erst am anfang
stehen die ja dringend brauchen weil die
fachkräfte fehlen glückauf liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen
lasst euch nicht unterkriegen wir stehen
an eurer seite aber nicht nur dem wort
nach sondern auch der tat lasst uns das
bundesweit einführen und ergänzen und
die bereiche die bislang bei der ddr 2.0
fehlen in der langzeitpflege jedes aber
tatsächlich immer geld da er kämpfen wir
um eine allgemeinverbindlichkeit bei den
tarifverträgen dafür dass das möglich
wird was der letzten legislatur bereits
ich leider scheiterte obwohl der
politische wille war da aber liebe
kollegen kollegen das instrument blick
auf den tisch im arbeitsministerium
geschaffen schaffen wir den rahmen um es
einsetzen zu können und es geht
schließlich um endlich auch um eine
bessere finanzielle ausstattung der in
lauterbach ankündigte dass die
kassenbeiträge bei normal verdienenden
ansteigen müssten sorgen wir dafür dass
alle einzahlen in die pflege und
krankenversicherung sehr geehrte damen
und herren ich kann mir zum schluss
geschlagen dass heute vor was sich in
der gesellschaft langen durchgesetzt hat
und selbst in koalitionsfragen eintrag
gefunden hat eine entlastung in der
krankenpflege und bessere bezahlung in
der langzeitpflege doch das
gesundheitsministerium das wissen sie
auch in spielen also bei uns schon
schluss papier ist geduldig die
beschäftigten sind es nicht mehr die
linke greift die forderung jetzt auf wir
freuen uns auf die debatte und vor allem
auf die umsetzung fiel vielen dank
die sowie pienaar
die linke fordert ja unter anderem die
zeitnahe einführung des pflegepersonal
regelung der pflegepersonal regelung 2.0
die laute ministerium die umsetzung wird
dort aktuell noch geprüft andreas
philippi jetzt in seiner ersten rede für
den deutschen bundestag spd fraktion
wir beide haben eine gemeinsame
persönliche geschichte erzählt ich ihn
aber hinterher
als schlimm ist das angebot
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und heute sage ich besonders liebe
pflegende
am heutigen internationalen tag der
pflege
möchte ich sie liebe pflegende ganz
besonders begrüßen
und ihre arbeit für andere menschen und
für unsere gesellschaft würdigen und
hier einmal ganz deutlich
danke sagen
ich freue mich dass ich als arzt der nun
auch in der politik tätig ist heute in
meiner ersten rede im deutschen
bundestag die möglichkeit habe die
arbeit und die arbeitsbedingungen von
pass von fast zwei millionen pflegenden
in deutschland hervorzuheben und hier im
hohen haus zum thema zu machen
der der heutige tag fällt nicht aus
zufall auf den geburtstag der britischen
krankenschwester florence nightingale im
jahre 1820 zurück und erinnert uns alle
an die pioniere der modernen
krankenpflege
sie sagte und ich zitiere
pflege ist eine kunst
und wenn sie zur kunst gemacht werden
soll bedarf es einer ebenso harten
vorbereitung wie für die arbeit eines
malers oder bildhauers zitat ende
damit hat florence nightingale maßstäbe
an dem beruf und das werk der pflegenden
gesetzt die bis heute gelten
beziehungsweise gelten sollten denn um
diese kunst erfolgreich auszuüben bedarf
es auch gute arbeitsbedingungen und
diese aufgabe und damit das erbe von
florence nightingale ist noch lange
nicht erfüllt
was sich die pionierin der modernen
krankenpflege damals sicher kaum
vorstellen konnte sind die enormen
zusätzlichen herausforderungen die auf
die pflegenden heute zu kommen und die
ich heute einmal kurz nennen möchte zur
umsetzung der guten kunst gehört heute
nämlich auch eine sehr anspruchsvolle
fachspezifische aus und weiterbildung
sowie enormer zusätzlicher
dokumentationsaufwand neben der
eigentlichen pflege
meine damen und herren pflegende und
damit meine ich sowohl die professionell
pflegenden als auch die ehrenamtlichen
und die pflegenden angehörigen
sie sind wahrlich systemrelevant
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich weiß
selbst pflegekraft und sage deshalb
selbstkritisch es kann und darf nicht
bei sonntagsreden bleiben deshalb haben
wir als spd schon in der letzten
wahlperiode viele berechtigte
forderungen des bündnisses vierer
wettbewerb in der pflege umgesetzt
umgesetzt um eine angemessene vergütung
der pflegekräfte und der refinanzierung
sicherzustellen
wir haben im rahmen der konzertierten
aktion
pflege
in der imam der konzertierten aktion
pflege und im pflege löhne verbesserungs
gesetz politische weichenstellungen
vorgenommen
der ganzheitliche ansatz eines
allgemeinverbindlichen pflege
tarifvertrages wie sich allerdings nicht
in der letzten wahlperiode komplett
umsetzen und warum da haben die kollegen
von der linken in ihrem antrag nicht
ganz unrecht weil es ein ärgerliches
veto der arbeitsrechtlichen kommission
hat der caritas gegeben hat ich vernehme
inzwischen auch andere stimmen aus dem
präsidium des caritas so dass die
begründete hoffnung haben diesen weg
eines branchentarifvertrages mit einer
lohnerhöhung für viele pflegende in
dieser wahlperiode umzusetzen
zunächst aber verfolgen wir als
ampelkoalition das zwischenziel aus dem
gesundheits versorgungs
weiterentwicklungsgesetz der vergangenen
wahlperiode
nämlich dass arbeitgeber in der pflege
am 19 2022
mindestens auf höhe eines regionalen
tarifvertrages bezahlen müssen um auch
weiterhin im rahmen der
pflegeversicherung zugelassen zu sein
sehr geehrte damen und herren nun sind
wir aber in der zwanzigsten wahlperiode
und die pflegenden dürfen berechtigt
fragen was habt ihr darüber hinaus für
uns vor hier ist der koalitionsvertrag
eindeutig und ambitioniert meine
fraktionskollegen werden diese in ihrem
weiteren beiträgen noch konkretisieren
aber völlig unumstritten ist dass wir
weitere verbesserungen bei den
arbeitsbedingungen der pflegenden
umsetzen müssen dass wir pflegepersonal
durch gute und faire arbeit halten
zurückgewinnen und neu gewinnen müssen
und dass wir uns um florence nightingale
würdig zu erweisen es schaffen müssen
dass man gesund und zufrieden im beruf
der pflegenden auch gut alt werden kann
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wie kann der pflegeberuf attraktiver
gemacht werden das beschäftigt die
abgeordnete ja nun schon eine ganze
weile denn es gibt auch viele stellen
die noch immer unbesetzt sind diana
stöcker spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen heute ist der
internationale tag der pflege er ist den
menschen gewidmet die derzeit weltweit
in den pflegeberufen arbeiten und
kranken und alten helfen allen
pflegerinnen und pflegern ein großes
dankeschön für diesen ihren dienst am
menschen für ihren einsatz tag für tag
ein einsatz der viel verlangt eine hohe
fachliche kompetenz aber auch soziale
kompetenz empathie fürsorglichkeit und
zugewandtheit
[Applaus]
wir sind uns sicherlich alle einig dass
wir einen großen mangel an fachkräften
in der pflege haben und alles dafür tun
müssen und gerade vor dem hintergrund
der demografischen entwicklung um sofort
mehr fachkräfte auszubilden
beziehungsweise zu gewinnen der antrag
der linken geht dabei jedoch in eine
völlig falsche richtung er verdreht
warum in der letzten legislaturperiode
beim flüge löhne verbesserungs gesetz
mit dem grundsätzlich ein für die pflege
allgemeinverbindlicher tarifvertrag in
deutschland möglich gemacht wird ein
mitspracherecht aufgenommen wurde und
der antrag vertritt auch warum die
kirchlichen träger in den verhandlungen
dem vorgelegten tarifvertrag nicht
zugestimmt haben liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der linken man muss also sehr
genau hinschauen und sich kundig machen
bevor man irgendwelche position
übernimmt die keiner der hand und fuß
haben
zunächst zur regelung der mitsprache und
zustimmung dass sie als vetorecht
bezeichnen die beiden großen
wohlfahrtsverbände caritas und diakonie
stellen einen co ein anteil an
pflegeplätzen in deutschland bereit sie
haben damit auch eine sehr große
bedeutung in einer für alle gültigen
tariftreue regelung
und der vorgelegte tarifvertrag welcher
für alle träger der pflegeeinrichtungen
gelten sollte und für den die
allgemeinverbindlichkeit beantragt wurde
wurde von einer minigruppe von
arbeitgebern mit verdi ausgehandelt er
war von anfang an zum scheitern
verurteilt denn eine arbeitgeber gruppe
die nur fünf prozent der pflegeplätze in
deutschland vor hält kann nur schwerlich
einen allgemeinverbindlichen
tarifvertrag verhandeln der der mehrheit
von 95 prozent diktiert was umgesetzt
gehört solche konstrukte würden beim
bundesverfassungsgericht aufgehoben
werden
und was waren die finanziellen
tarifforderungen diese lagen und nun
bitte genau zuhören verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen deutlich unter denen die
die kritisierten kirchlichen arbeitgeber
den pflegekräften zahlen das hätte den
pflegekräften keinen euro mehr gebracht
im gegenteil es hätte die gefahr
bestanden
hätte die gefahr bestanden dass die
kassen in den verhandlungen die
niedrigen löhne des neuen tarifvertrags
als maßstab und mithin zum norm lohn
genommen hätten und entweder hätten die
kirchlichen träger die löhne der
pflegekräfte senken müssen was natürlich
niemand möchte oder diese träger während
in die unterfinanzierung geraten welche
zum beispiel durch kommunale zuschüsse
hätten kompensiert werden müssen
kurzum die kirchlichen arbeitgeber
hatten schon immer eine hohe
tarifbindung und tariftreue mit sehr
gutem niveau sie zahlen auch die
altenpflege auf dem krankenpflege niveau
und unterscheiden eben nicht zwischen
langzeit und krankenhaus pflegekraft es
kann also nicht davon die rede sein dass
die kirchlichen wohlfahrtsverbände eine
gute bezahlung in der pflege verhindern
das genaue gegenteil ist der fall das
was sie heute in ihrem antrag fordern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen führt
also nicht dazu dass der pflegeberuf
attraktiver wird er führt auch nicht
dazu dass die löhne für die
beschäftigten steigen denn die kirchen
bilden mit ihrem guten lohnniveau ein
bollwerk gegen jegliche nivellierung des
tarifniveaus nach unten es wäre im
gegenteil
es wäre im gegenteil wünschenswert dass
alle arbeitgeber in der pflege ihren
beschäftigten dieses niveau zu halten
und nach dem scheitern der
allgemeinverbindlichkeit weiß wichtig
dass auf betreiben von
gesundheitsminister jens spahn zum ende
der letzten wahlperiode ein gesetz
verabschiedet wurde das den pflegerinnen
und pfleger im nicht kirchlichen bereich
ab september dieses jahres mehr lohn
sicherheit bieten wird mit dem
[Applaus]
mit dem gesundheitsversorgung
weiterentwicklungsgesetz wurde nämlich
geregelt dass nur noch
pflegeeinrichtungen zur versorgung
zugelassen werden die ihre pflege und
betreuungskräfte auf basis eines
tarifvertrages bezahlen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von den
linken ich habe in meinem wahlkreis mit
sehr vielen einrichtungen und
pflegekräften sowohl von privaten
kirchlichen als auch kommunalen trägern
gesprochen und alle haben mir gesagt es
ist schon lange nicht mehr die vergütung
die pflegekräfte von ihrem beruf abhält
und sie in andere berufsfelder abwandern
lässt viel viel wichtiger sind die
arbeitsbedingungen die verbessert werden
müssen das zentrale thema ist mehr
kolleginnen und kollegen eine bessere
personalausstattung und verbindliche
personalbemessung in der pflege sowohl
in der langzeitpflege als im krankenhaus
es geht des weiteren um themen wie
zeitdruck in der pflege zum beispiel
durch eine überbordende bürokratie
sierung es geht darum dass tatsächlich
den pflegeberuf die wertschätzung fehlt
im man den pflegeberuf überreguliert und
ausgebildeten und erfahrenen fachkräften
nicht die freiheit gibt das zu tun was
sie gelernt haben nämlich menschen
kompetent und gut zu pflegen auf
augenhöhe mit anderen
gesundheitsfachberufen und wenn wir das
wieder ermöglichen bin ich mir sicher
werden die fachkräfte weiter mit großer
freude und engagement in der pflege
arbeiten
diana stöcker hat hier noch einmal
begründet warum die caritas im
vergangenen jahr nicht dem allgemeinen
tarifvertrag zugestimmt hat wie ihr
vorgeschlagen wurde unter anderem vom
arbeitgeberverband
die heutige debatte steht ganz im
zeichen des tags der pflegenden der
pflegenden in den familien und der
professionell pflegenden die nicht erst
in der pandemie sondern auch davor
herausragendes leisten und geleistet
haben wir alle sind ihnen nicht nur dann
schuldig sondern wir sind schuldig
weitgehende reformen die wir auf den
bringt weg bringen wollen um trotz
steigender zahlen von pflegebedürftigen
auf die wir uns einstellen müssen gute
pflege auch in den nächsten jahrzehnten
sicherstellen zu können
und dafür ist ganz wesentlich
ganz wesentlich die aufwertung der
professionellen pflege die
weiterentwicklung der pflegeberufe
natürlich attraktive arbeitsbedingungen
und natürlich auch gute bezahlung
das verbot der das veto recht der
kirchen abzuschaffen hier ist die linke
heute fordert ist rechtlich sehr
umstritten wir haben uns damit
ausführlich befasst und wir haben im
koalitionsvertrag schon angekündigt und
werden das auch umsetzen gemeinsam mit
den kirchen hier zu einem gemeinsamen
weg zu kommen und dann werden wir auch
mit entsprechenden vorschlägen hier ins
parlament zurück zu kommen
auch die verbesserung der
arbeitsbedingungen liegt dieser
regierung sehr am herzen und ich möchte
hier nur beispielhaft die
familienfreundlichen arbeitszeiten aber
aber die große herausforderung meine
damen und herren die große
herausforderung ist wir brauchen mehr
personal wir brauchen mehr menschen die
bereit sind in diesem beruf zu geben und
daher wollen wir die professionelle
fachpflege aufwerten mit neuen
berufsbildern und mit mehr verantwortung
im gesundheitswesen wir wollen die
kommunen die gemeinden dörfer stadtteile
in die lage versetzen mit dem
demografischen wandel umzugehen und ihn
zu meistern durch gute pflege vor ort
durch die förderung von gesundheit durch
die zusammenarbeit der gesundheitsberufe
in einer gesundheitsregion die neue
qualifikation der communications wird
dazu einen wichtigen beitrag leisten
können und neue berufliche perspektiven
auch für pflegende eröffnen hierzu
gehört eigenverantwortliches arbeiten
und die übertragungen hype und licher
tätigkeiten wie wir das vorsehen und
natürlich meine damen und herren und
natürlich brauchen wir eine angemessene
vertretung der pflege der
professionellen pflege in den
entscheidungsgremien des deutschen
gesundheitswesens unter anderem den dort
neben gemeinsamen bundesausschuss und
deshalb stärken und unterstützen wir den
pflegerat als organisierte stimme ja
professionell
professionelle fachpflege im gemeinsamen
bundesausschuss längst überfällig hier
endlich dafür zu sorgen dass auch in den
gremien des bundes der
entscheidungsgremien in unseren für in
unserem gesundheitswesen die pflege
einen angemessenen platz bekommt
angehört wird und auch mit entscheiden
kann wie gute pflege für die zukunft
sichergestellt würde ich danke ihnen für
die aufmerksamkeit
soweit kordula schulz-asche hier in der
debatte zu zwei anträge von der
linksfraktion die passend zum
internationalen tag der pflegenden heute
beraten werden nächster redner ist
martin sichert für die armee fraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
die ausgaben des bundes für
gesundheitspolitik haben sich in den
letzten drei jahren verdreifacht
dabei wird das gesundheitssystem nicht
besser sondern schlechter
pharmalobbyisten und einzelne
protagonisten verdienen sich eine
goldene nase und die patienten bleiben
auf der strecke die
gesundheitsversorgung wird immer
schlechter die krankenversicherung wird
hingegen immer teurer viele menschen
bekommen keine termine bei fachärzten
und wenn doch müssen sie oft monatelang
warten die ärztliche versorgung auf dem
land weist bedeutende lücken auf in der
pflege fehlen über 30.000 beschäftigte
die ampel macht nichts um diese probleme
anzugehen karl lauterbach ist kein
gesundheitsminister der tut nichts um
die gesundheit der menschen zu stärken
karl lauterbach
karl lauterbach ist ein krankheits
minister der ständig neue horrorzahlen
erfindet um die menschen krank vor angst
zu machen das tief
dass die bundesregierung die echten
probleme im gesundheitswesen ignoriert
ist eine katastrophe noch katastrophaler
sind nur noch die hier vorgelegten
anträge von den linken sie wollen mehr
bürokratie in der pflege dabei ist eines
der hauptprobleme im pflegebereich dass
sich bereits jetzt jede vierte
pflegekraft mehr als die hälfte der
arbeitszeit mit bürokratie beschäftigt
78 prozent der pflegekräfte sind
zufrieden mit ihrem job aber zugleich
man 90 prozent über zu viel bürokratie
wenn wir den beruf attraktiv machen
wollen dürfen wir nicht neue bürokratie
einführen so wie sie das wollen sondern
wir müssen bürokratie abbauen die
pflegekraft ist doch pflegekraft
geworden weil sie sich um die menschen
kümmern will
[Applaus]
hätte sie einen job gewollt indem sie
formulare ausfüllt wäre sie stattdessen
schreibkraft geworden bauen will
bürokratie ab sorgen wir dafür dass
künftig die berufsbezeichnung stimmt
weil sich die pflegekraft endlich der
pflege mit aller kraft widmen kann das
ist auch im sinne der patienten wenn sie
meinen ich hätte hier keine ahnung wie
sie hier gerade behaupten dann sollten
sie sich mal mit den zahlen daten und
fakten beschäftigen und mit den
problemen das ist doch das was wir
angehen müssen und dass das von dem mann
von der ampel kommt ist eine absolute
katastrophe und es zeigt wie blind sie
sind für die wahren probleme die wir in
diesem land haben es gibt noch andere
themen außer corona
die linken beantragt hier auch noch dass
die wertschaffende bevölkerung noch mehr
von ihrem hart verdienten geld an den
staat ab drückt die linke nennt das
gerecht ich nenne das staatliche abzocke
wir sind doch jetzt schon weltmeister
bei steuern und abgaben steuern und
abgaben müssen endlich runter nicht noch
weiter hoch die menschen arbeiten
oft sogar in zwei oder drei jobs und sie
verlieren trotzdem immer mehr
lebensstandard die preise für
lebensmittel für sprit und energie
explodieren die mieten haben sich in den
letzten acht jahren verdoppelt gehen sie
doch mal raus schauen sie bei einem
autohaus vorbei was da die fahrzeuge die
auf dem hof stehen inzwischen kosten und
dann fragen sie mal den mechaniker der
der arbeitet wie lange er arbeiten muss
um so viel geld beiseitezulegen die
lebenshaltungskosten geraten aus dem
ruder bei der stadt ständig in alle
möglichen märkte eingreift
wann sich eine empfindet schadenfreude
darüber dass kevin kühnert wegen
mietpreis bremse und mieten decke keine
wohnung in berlin findet ich persönlich
habe er mitleid mit den millionen
mietern die unter dieser politik leiden
und nichts dafür können sie wollen wir
in diesen anträgen mehr bürokratie
höhere abgaben also immer mehr
staatliche eingriffe die schaden
anrichten sie lösen kein einziges
problem sie schaffen nur immer neue
[Applaus]
jeder anträge auch heute sind wieder
typischer murks von markt in deutschland
sicher nicht bauch das ist schade denn
wir bräuchten dringend bessere
arbeitsbedingungen in der pflege hören
sie insbesondere von der ampel auf immer
nur den pflegekräften zu danken sondern
sorgen sie endlich für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen in der pflege
die einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
hört sofort aufgehoben die bürokratie
muss deutlich reduziert werden und der
beruf muss finanziell attraktiver werden
das muss endlich angegangen werden
goalie martin sicherheit von der afg hat
hier bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach deutlich angegriffen der ist
hier nicht im plenum stattdessen sehen
wir jetzt hier auch seinen
parlamentarischen staatssekretär edgar
franke staatssekretär im
gesundheitsministerium vertritt hier
seinen chef
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie uns am heutigen tag der pflegenden
wieder über pflege reden
uns über passt über vorschläge getraut
mit ihrer seite aber dass wenn wir nicht
gewohnt und von daher ist es auch nicht
so schlimm wir sagen herzlich danke
allen pflegenden und eigentlich müsste
jeden tag tag der pflegenden sein
aber wir stehen auch in der pflicht die
arbeitsbedingungen in der pflege
nachhaltig zu verbessern und deshalb
haben wir uns als fortschritts koalition
auf viele maßnahmen dazu verständigt
eine davon ist die zügige einführung der
pflegepersonal regelung 2.0 denn die
derzeit noch bestehenden personal
untergrenzen sind denkbar ungeeignet
sie zeigen lediglich ab wann die
personalbesetzung absolut kritisch wird
dabei sind die untergrenzen wie wir
freien demokraten immer befürchtet haben
zu obergrenzen geworden was wir wollen
ist eine qualitäts basierte
personalbemessung
mit der abschaffung
mit der abschaffung der untergrenzen
allein ist es deshalb nicht getan und
auch die pr 2.0 wird rote haltelinien
umfassen diese dürfen aber nicht mehr
die richtschnur für die
personalbemessung sein dabei muss klar
sein die pr 2.0 ist ein lernendes system
und deshalb ist uns wichtig dass nicht
an den pflegenden vorbei sondern mit
ihnen geplant wird der laufende prozess
muss offen sein für ständige evaluation
und notwendige anpassungen auch die
interprofessionelle zusammenarbeit mit
anderen therapie berufen müssen wir
stärken denn eine gute
gesundheitsversorgung gelingt nur im
team
pflegewissenschaft und pflegemanagement
gehören eingebunden die wissenschaft
liefert die erkenntnisse aus der
versorgungs und pflegeforschung und das
ist nicht nur für die pflegenden
relevant sondern für die gesellschaft
insgesamt für eine gute und
bedarfsgerechte patientenversorgung und
natürlich müssen die besonderen
versorgungssituation auf der
intensivstation und in der pädiatrie
personell anders abgebildet werden
wir wissen dass alles wir brauchen da
keine nachhilfe von der linksfraktion
herr liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
den linken auch die arbeitsbedingungen
in der langzeitpflege werden wir
verbessern dieses problem mit einer
streichung des vetorechts der kirchen
lösen zu wollen ist jedoch glatt am ziel
vorbeigeschossen
so zu tun als seien kirchliche träger
für niedrige löhne in der langzeitpflege
verantwortlich ist einfach unredlich das
gegenteil ist der fall viele kirchliche
träger orientieren sich bei ihren
entlohnungen ohnehin an den tarif
entwicklungen im öffentlichen dienst
alle lohnerhöhungen werden hier in der
regel übernommen an der stelle machen
sie sich zu einfach liebe linksfraktion
eines klar um die arbeitsbedingungen in
der pflege zu verbessern braucht es mehr
als angemessene löhne auch hier brauchen
wir eine kluge personalbemessung die
studie von professor rothgang gibt gute
ansätze wir brauchen zum beispiel dort
eine hohe anzahl an pflege faschist
enten doch für deren ausbildung gibt es
aktuell noch keine bundesweit
einheitlichen qualitätsstandards
deswegen müssen wir das schnell regeln
und ebenso wie die kompetenzen dann in
der langzeitpflege verteilt werden all
diese fragen zeigen wie falsch und
kurzsichtig es ist bessere
arbeitsbedingungen in unseren
pflegeeinrichtungen durch diesen antrag
der linken erreichen zu wollen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lassen sie mich
abschließend noch einmal zum tag der
pflegenden zurückkommen immer wieder
fordern wir mehr anerkennung und
wertschätzung für die pflege
dazu gehört der schleichenden dpd
professionalisierung des berufs ein ende
zu setzen
schlegel braucht mehr
professionalisierung nicht weniger es
ist ein hochkomplexer beruf den menschen
nicht nur ergreifen um sich um andere
menschen kümmern zu können sondern weil
er anspruchsvoll ist und weil sie diesen
ansprüchen gerecht werden und diese
hochkomplexe beruf braucht eine starke
stimme eine starke stimme in unserer
gesellschaft eine starke stimme die von
der politik gehört wird die pflege
gehört in die entscheidungsgremien die
pflege gehört in den gba und zwar nicht
nur als stimme sondern auch mit
stimmrecht
[Applaus]
dämmerung für die pflege will kann hier
ein zeichen setzen vielen dank
frau würde gesetzlich
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin
bettina müller spd fraktion
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das a und
o von guter pflege ist ausreichendes ist
gut motiviertes und vor allem gut
ausgebildetes personal und ein
und ein personal nix der dieb der sich
auf die ständig verändernden pflege
settings auch einstellt und die neue
generalistisch orientierte ausbildung
macht die pflegekräfte fit für die
zukunft in der kranken und altenpflege
die ja immer mehr zusammenwächst aber
diese neue ausbildung zur pflegefachfrau
und zum pflegefachmann ist ja erst im
jahr 2020 unter überwiegend im herbst
angelaufen der erste ausbildungsjahrgang
befindet sich gerade mitten im zweiten
ausbildungsjahr und mit dem abschluss
der dreijährigen ausbildung ende 2023
wird diese erste kohorte dieser neuen
kräfte dann auf den stationen und in der
ambulanten pflege zum einsatz kommen wo
sie auch dringend gebraucht werden und
natürlich
und natürlich ruckelt ist da bei einer
so tief greifenden ausbildungsreform
noch hier und da etwas nicht jede
pflegeschule nicht jeder träger der
praktischen ausbildung findet auf anhieb
einen passenden kooperationspartner
und an vielen stellen gelten noch
übergangsregeln und öffnungsklauseln der
länder die ja für diese umsetzung dieser
pflege ausbildung zuständig ist und das
ist völlig normal und wird sich schnell
einspielen da bin ich mir sicher
deshalb brauchen wir auch keine reform
der reform ich wundere mich dass manche
so was bereits zur halbzeit der ersten
ausbildung scorte fordern was wir
wirklich brauchen ist vertrauen in das
gelingen und vertrauen in die akteure
der pflegeausbildung und umgekehrt
müssen diese akteure auch darauf
vertrauen können dass politische
entscheidungen verlässlich sind und
bestand haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sinnvolle
nachbesserungen am pflegeberufe gesetz
wird es aber an zwei stellen geben und
das ist zum eigentlich hochschulische
pflegeausbildung die ja nicht so recht
in die gänge kommen will daher hätte ich
mir schon damals gewünscht dass die
pflegeausbildung die hochschulische
pflege als ausbildung als duales system
angelegt wird dann gäbe es auch hier
eine ausbildungsvergütung ohne die man
ja kaum jemanden für eine hochschulische
pflegeausbildung gewinnen kann aber
leider da gab es damals massiven
widerstand aus der union gegen dieses
vorhaben und wir wollen auch eine zweite
änderung einziehen und zwar wollen wir
es den reha kliniken und einrichtungen
der eingliederungshilfe
ermöglichen träger der pflegeausbildung
zu sein und dass wir zusätzliche
ausbildungskapazitäten schaffen und die
nachwuchsgewinnung auch in diesen
bereichen erleichtern problemloser
zwischenfrage des kollegen
hier wird es darauf ankommen die
kostenträger in den ausbildungsfonds
auch dann mit einzubinden liebe
kolleginnen kollegen wir stärken also
die fachkraft ausbildung weiter
verbessern die hochschulische
pflegeausbildung und wir haben uns auch
vorgenommen dass es eben schon zur
sprache gekommen auf der ebene darunter
die pflegeassistenz ausbildung zu
reformieren dass rothgang buch gutachten
ist schon erwähnt worden hat ja deutlich
aufgezeigt dass wir in diesem bereich
einen hohen personalbedarf haben wir
haben aber ist es auch angesprochen
worden leider seit vielen jahren ein
wildwuchs in den ländern einen
flickenteppich an unterschiedlichen
landesrechtlichen regelungen und deshalb
ist eine vereinheitlichen dieser vielen
ausbildungs varianten das anheben auf
ein einheitliches
qualifikationsniveau längst überfällig
auch weil wir damit natürlich die
aufstiegsmöglichkeiten von der hilfs und
assistenzkraft hin zur fachkraft bis zum
studium bis zum pflege studium deutlich
verbessern und damit auch die
berufsperspektiven
attraktiver gestalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen mit
diesen maßnahmen wird es uns gelingen
diesen schönen beruf und ich weiß ja
wovon ich spreche ich komme ja aus der
pflege für mehr man menschen attraktiv
zu machen
das können sie sich sparen wenn sie
schon man krankenhaus haben sie schon
mal da gearbeitet wegen kommen sie zum
schlüssel okay mit diesen maßnahmen wird
es uns gelingen mehr menschen für diesen
schönen beruf zu gewinnen ich bedanke
mich für ihre aufmerksam
herta müller von der spd hat hier noch
mal vorgestellt wie sie sich vorstellt
dass man mehr menschen für diesen beruf
gewinnen kann denn natürlich ist
arbeiten zwar schon 167 millionen
menschen in der pflege aber aufgrund des
demografischen wandels und der
zunehmenden zahl an pflegebedürftigen
dürften es in zukunft noch mehr werden
müssen
herr präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen
uns eint ein gemeinsames ziel den
fliegenden in deutschland mehr
wertschätzung und anerkennung zu teil
werden zu lassen und die
arbeitsbedingungen in der pflege zu
verbessern
denn früher oder später sind wir alle
mittelbar oder unmittelbar davon
betroffen
wir haben zwar nicht alle kinder aber
letztendlich alle eltern und spätestens
dann werden wir am eigenen leib spüren
mit welchem hohen einsatz pflegekräfte
sich um die bedürftigen kümmern ich
selbst bin bestens mit der situation
vertraut da ich direkt aus der praxis
kommen
auch ich weiß selbstverständlich dass
applaus und worte des dankes nur ein
kleiner teil aufrichtiger wertschätzung
sind dadurch werden wir aber die
arbeitsbedingungen in der pflege nicht
annähernd verbessern und der pflege
bonus führt auch nicht dazu dass wir
irgendeine unbesetzte stelle besetzt
daher es ist ein ganzheitlicher blick
auf die pflege notwendig und viele
redner haben das auch schon vor mir
gesagt wir müssen das thema pflege neu
denken
und in diesem zusammenhang kann ich nur
sagen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
kirchlichen einrichtungen sind ein
unverzichtbarer bestandteil in unserer
pflegelandschaft
insofern ist es nur folgerichtig dass
man auch kirchliche geführte einrichtung
in geplante veränderungsprozesse mit
einbindet das gilt es anzuerkennen
ideologisch motiviert die kritik ist
hier völlig unangebracht
sie wollen mit ihrem antrag ein
faktisches vetorecht der kirchlichen
kommission streichen und führen an dass
das veto der caritas ein bundesweit
allgemein mündlichen tarifvertrag für
die langzeitpflege verhindert hat diese
kritik ist für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar faktisch hätte eine
zustimmung der caritas nämlich bedeutet
dass die eigenen beschäftigten
schlechter gestellt worden wären dass
kürze wahrheit dazu
und bei den löhnen und gehältern auch
das gehört zur wahrheit dazu bewegen wir
uns auch in der pflege teilweise
mittlerweile in wirklich guten
dimensionen
auszubilden im ersten ausbildungsjahr
bekommen mittlerweile über 1000 euro
ausbildungsvergütung das ist gut und das
ist richtig
es reicht also nicht immer nur nach mehr
geld zu schreien wir müssen uns sie an
die rahmenbedingungen und damit einen
die arbeitsbedingungen heranwagen
fachlicher langsamer zwischenfrage des
grünen
fraktion die linke nein letztlich und
wenn wir jetzt auf das thema pr 2.0
schauen kann ich nur sagen das
patientenwohl steht uns als union an
erster stelle
deswegen ist eine ausreichende personal
deckung dass a
in den letzten beiden wahlperioden haben
wir mit dem krankenhausstruktur gesetzt
und mit mehr 5 liege personal störungs
gesetzen bereits wirksame maßnahme
entsprechend auf den weg gebracht und
wenn wir uns jetzt diesem thema widmen
dann müssen wir auch registrieren dass
wir im medizinischen bereichen besonders
im stationären bereich bereits jetzt
eine überversorgung haben im vergleich
zu anderen ländern und das problem des
pflegenotstand es ist daher auch
teilweise hausgemacht und wird durch
eine pr 2.0 nicht gelöst werden wir
befinden uns heute in einem system in
dem krankenhäuser alles an personal was
mit dem thema pflege am bett zu tun hat
refinanziert bekommen das war damals ein
wirklich guter ansatz den die große
koalition gemeinsam beschlossen hat aber
es hat sich jedoch herausgestellt
dass dies zum teil falsche anreize
auslöst und das müssen wir wirklich auch
selbstkritisch anerkennen
aber was bedeutet das jetzt für die
praxis die entwicklung geht jetzt ein
das ausgegliederte arbeiten die
hauswirtschaft mittlerweile von
fachkräften gemacht werden damit diese
refinanziert werden
fachkräfte wird alles was am bett sp
finanziert das müssen wir uns mal
gedanklich vor vor augen führen und wenn
ein krankenhaus zusätzliche pflegekräfte
einstellt kriegt es natürlich alles
refinanziert das ist richtig nicht
richtig ist dass bekannten haus bekommt
auch eine finanzierung und zwar
unabhängig von den wirklichen bedarf
unten auch das gehört zur jetzigen
wahrheit dazu es gibt also keine anreize
mehr im system personal effizient
einzusetzen
aber da müssen wir wieder hin
eine lösung wäre dass sie wieder die
aggies einführen die sind pflegeaufwand
beinhalten dass wir nicht dass pflege
budget separat verglühten und ein weiter
wichtiger ansatz ist die abschaffung der
fachkraftquote in pflegeeinrichtungen
und krankenhäusern
denn auf pflegehilfskräfte erbringen
hervorragende leistung das muss
anerkannt werden es gibt mittlerweile
genug regularien und qualitätskriterien
die eine erfolgskontrolle möglich machen
und die werden natürlich auch in zukunft
jede menge pflegepersonal brauchen wenn
wir uns die demografische entwicklung
anschauen
aber mit geld alleine werden wir es
nicht schaffen und hier ist es wichtig
dass wir die bürokratie abbauen dass wir
die regulierung abbauen und dem
pflegepersonal mehr eigenverantwortlich
möglich machen wir müssen ihm die luft
zum atmen leistung das ist wichtig
und diese weniger regulären die sollten
wir uns wirklich als ziel setzen
ich danke ihnen die geplante umsetzung
der pr 2.0 steht zwar im
koalitionsvertrag
der ampel aber mittlerweile hört man
auch aus dem b umgeht dass das nicht
unbedingt die lösung ist das ist zu
begrüßen und die cdu/csu beide anträge
ablehnt vielen dank
sobald die ankündigung von simon &
burkhardt allerdings bevor dieser antrag
abgelehnt werden kann wird er erst
einmal den entsprechenden ausschüssen
beraten und kommt dann ihr wieder ins
plenum ricarda lang jetzt für bündnis
90/die grünen und kollegen und sehr
geehrte pflegende die heute hier diese
debatte verfolgen ich war seit tagen zu
besuch in münster bei einem streik
kosten von werden dort vor ort wo
pflegende für einen tarifvertrag
entlastungen streiken auf die straße
gehen und sie haben dort eine für mich
sehr besondere aktion gemacht und zwar
haben sie sich dafür entschieden nicht
uns politikerinnen die zu besuch
gekommen sind erst mal reden zu lassen
sondern dass menschen aus der pflege aus
verschiedenen professionen dort an der
klinik uns von ihren erfahrungen
berichtet haben und sie haben davon
erzählt warum sie sich für diesen beruf
entschieden haben warum ist ja auch
immer noch davon überzeugt sind dass es
ein schöner das ist ein unfassbar
wichtiger beruf ist aber sie haben auch
von überforderungen gesprochen vom
situationen wo man ängste hatte wo man
allein gelassen war wo die kollegin
gefehlt hat und dann alleine für mehrere
patienten zuständig war und vom moment
musst du das gefühl hatten dass sie der
grund warum es diesmal in diesem beruf
gegangen sind menschen in krankheit im
alten würde zu erhalten dass sie diesem
anspruch nicht mehr gerecht werden
können und damit tanzen natürlich nicht
nur ihre eigenen geschichten erzählt
sonst habe auch die geschichten ihrer
patientin erzählt denn das ist glaube
ich unfassbar wichtig dass wir immer uns
in erinnerung rufen und da bin ich auch
solidarisch mit den menschen die gerade
streiken der pflege wenn pflegekräfte
streiken dann tun sie das niemals nur
für sich selbst sonst die zu uns ist
immer auch ihre patientinnen sie tun ist
ein menschenwürdiges gesundheitssystem
und damit tun sie es uns alle
und gleichzeitig reicht ist natürlich
nicht als politisch solidarisch zu sein
mit streiks sondern wir müssen die
rahmenbedingungen schaffen die es
menschen ermöglichen dauerhaften diesen
job zu bleiben denn der beruf ist für
viele menschen nach wie vor attraktiv
wir haben es häufiger zahlen gesehen
dass india hat 2022 mehr menschen sich
seine ausbildung in der pflege
entscheiden als 20 21 der fall war das
ist ein gutes signal aber wir sehen auch
dass immer wieder menschen diesen beruf
nach nur ein paar jahren verlassen weil
sie mit der beförderung weil es mit der
bearbeitung nicht klar kommt und deshalb
machen wir uns nach einem großen
stillstand nicht nicht so aufregen ist
nicht gut von puls nach einem großen
stillstand in den letzten jahren erlebt
haben müssen wir jetzt rangehen diese
rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern und das
tun wir mit ganz vielen maßnahmen die
schon genannt wurden das tool mit
familienfreundlichen arbeitszeiten damit
für menschen auch wirklich besser und
einfacher wird in diesem beruf zu
arbeiten
das tool mit einer anhebung der löhne
gerade im bereich der altenpflege das
tut mir der professionalisierung dieser
berufe und das tun wir es
selbstverständlich auch in dem die
endlich eine gute personalbemessung auf
den weg bringt mit der pr 2.0 dafür
sorgen dass der ausnahmezustand lichte
normalität ist sondern die normalität
eine gute ausstattung mit personal ist
der freund zu den koalitionsvertrag
universi zustimmung zum
koalitionsvertrag stand dass sie auch
sehr schön klar ist aber auch wir
schauen auf die pflege aber die pflege
ist immer nur so gut wie das ganze
system in dem sie arbeitet und auch das
war eine messe die menschen noch mit
gegeben haben die dort gestreikt haben
verbessert unsere arbeitsbedingungen
aber denkt auch an die physiotherapeutin
denn die menschen die verschiedenen
therapien berufen und zusammenarbeiten
denkt an die reinigungskräfte in unseren
kliniken denkt an die menschen die wir
als hilfskräfte arbeiten
all diese menschen brauchen bessere
arbeitsbedingungen in das
gesundheitssystem wird nicht
funktionieren dann gegeneinander von
ärzten pflegekräften und es wird nur
funktionieren wenn wir all den
profession in dem unterstützen was sie
können und wenn sich all das mit guten
arbeitsbedingungen tatsächlich ausüben
können frau königin lang erlauben sie
den zwischenfrage des belegen sorge aus
der cdu/csu-fraktion vielen dank das
bringt mich zu meinem letzten punkt und
denke eher dass wir sehr gerne dass wir
sehr gerne und sehr notwendigerweise
hier über probleme in der pflege
sprechen und das ist auch wichtig ist
über die fehler die in den letzten
jahren gemacht wurden und über
lösungsansätze
ich würde mir aber wünschen dass nicht
immer und das kostet häufig über die
pflege gesprochen wird als ob diese
menschen eine opposition
und dann diese menschen sind keine opfer
sondern sie sind ganz im gegenteil sie
sind menschen eine große expertise mit
einem grossen wissen und es sollten in
zukunft pflegekräfte auch was genau das
behandeln dass sie sind experten für die
zukunft unseres gesundheitssystems und
in diesem sinne vielen vielen dank
kriegshaber lang oder das ist mitglied
informieren ausschuss und pflege ist
schon eines ihrer themen dass sie immer
wieder angesprochen hat und natürlich
ist sie auch parteivorsitzender der
grünen
nächste rednerin ist jetzt christina
bauen sie ist mitglied der afg fraktion
und auch im gesundheitsausschuss
mitglied
[Applaus]
präsident meine damen und herren die
immer schlechteren arbeitsbedingungen in
der pflege und der daraus entstandene
mangel an pflegekräften sind ganz sicher
keine plötzlich aufgetretenen probleme
ihre jahrelange ignoranz trägt wir jetzt
immer deutlicherer früchte die
demografie als potenzieren aber
ebenfalls bekannter faktor kommt hinzu
und ihre praxis der vergangenheit sich
einfach an fachkräften aus dem ausland
bedienen zu können findet ein ende
pflegen heißt sie doch nicht nur kranke
oder alte menschen zu verwalten sondern
sich auch liebevoll um sie zu kümmern
gerade dieser soziale aspekt ist für
viele die eigentliche motivation diesen
beruf zu erlernen und auszuüben die
dokumentationspflicht ist es ganz sicher
nicht deshalb kann eine aufwertung der
pflegetätigkeit nur gelingen wenn wir
endlich wieder gesundheit und pflege als
daseinsvorsorge und nicht als ware
betrachten und den pflegern auf den
entsprechenden freiraum geben zeit mit
den pflegebedürftigen verbringen zu
können nur dann wird der beruf auch
wieder attraktiv dass es ihnen allen
hier im parlament die linken
eingeschlossen wenig um wertschätzung
oder ein funktionierendes
gesundheitswesen geht zeigte sich
besonders in ihrem umgang mit den
pflegekräften in der korona zeit und mit
dem corolla bonus bei den ungeimpfte
ausgeschlossen werden sollen oder der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht sie
haben gezeigt dass die pfleger als bloße
erfüllungsgehilfen sind
unzählige pflegekräfte werden von ihnen
aktuell regelrecht aussortiert weil sie
nicht geimpft sind und das schlimmste
sie beharren auf ihrer fehlentscheidung
obwohl die caritas erst gestern sogar
von einem pflege drohenden pflege
kollaps warnte
überlegen sie schon mal die sie diese
leute die sie wie aussätzige behandelt
haben jemals wieder in unser
gesundheitssystem zurückholen können
denn sie werden dringend gebraucht
immer mehr pfleger unabhängig vom
impfstatus fordern inzwischen offen den
rücktritt laut von minister lauterbach
wegen erwiesener inkompetenz wie die
heutigen sich teilweise konträr
widersprechen den äußerungen und
anordnungen immer kürzere halbwertszeit
zeigen vor allem aber fordern sie ihren
rücktritt herr lauterbach ist leider
nicht anwesend werden der von ihnen
betriebenen spaltung der pflegekräfte in
gute geimpfte und schlechte von gamestar
ich schließe mich dieser forderung
uneingeschränkt an vielen dank
vielen dank frau konnte den drv haben
bevor ich dem publikum man das wort
erteilen kleine anmerkung zur
geschäftsführer-kollege sorge nach lesen
hilft in diesem fall auch weiter wenn
eine rednerin ihre zwischenfragen nicht
zulässt rechtfertigt das nicht unbedingt
eine kurzintervention die muss im
übrigen beantragt werden von ihrem pdf
und ich muss sie genehmigen was ich
nicht getan hätte insofern sich da schon
eher gering
der kollege sorge wenn sie wenn sie eine
verständnis frage an frau langsam gehen
sie einfach zu ihr ich bin sicher sie
wird ihn dabei als nächste hat das wort
der kollege größer dr kurze erklärung
hier von bundestags vizepräsident
wolfgang kubicki und nächste reden haben
wie angekündigt andere ullmann
fdp-fraktion
und gesundheitspolitischer sprecher
seiner fraktion
präsident hatte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
ich hoffe dass jetzt nächste ein
bisschen mehr kompetenz zeigt es geht
nicht hier nicht im print wenn eine
partei hier vorne steht und sagt die
impfen sorgt dafür dass keine leute mehr
in der pflege arbeiten da frage ich mich
welche den schuss nicht gehört haben
dass man hier sagt gut funktioniert
heute
auch die sachsen sind kluge menschen und
können aufgeklärt werden also
tschuldigung bitte dass sie hinter
diskriminiert unterwegs sind ja folgte
jetzt meine damen und herren ein
wichtiger tag internationalen tag der
pflege und die probleme in der pflege
ist sind uns allen bekannt wir haben
eigentlich gar kein erkenntnis- mangel
dann auch als arzt der 35 jahre lang in
der klinik in krankenhäusern gearbeitet
die probleme in der pflege nur zu gut
bekannt auch der kollege philipp hat ja
gerade auch erwähnte kommen ja aus der
praxis und die frustrationen sind uns
nur zu gut bekannt die uns auch
übermittelt worden sind und auch die
frustration bei uns bei der erster
schafft ist ja genau so groß weil wir
auch den pflegenden ja unbedingt helfen
wollen und es gelingt nicht immer denn
eins ist klar wir wollen ein
gesundheitssystem das bedarfsgerecht ist
und mit menschlicher wärme und an weiter
so kann es natürlich nicht geben
da wo wir sagen wir morgen sie eine
zwischenfrage des kollegen sorge der hat
ja so unheimlich viele auf dem herzen ja
wir herrn sorge kann ich gleich ob
privat sprechen die vielen absagen ist
heute schon bis nach 1 uhr und lieber
herr sorge ich glaube ich habe
verständnis für die kolleginnen kollegen
im bundestag keine überstunden machen
sollten
ja aber das ist das können wir gleich
noch privat ich mache jetzt meine rede
weiter herr präsident und das würde ich
gerne machen denn bild der ansätze haben
wir hier für die pflege brauche mittel
und kurzfristige lösungsansätzen wird
müssen eine bedarfsgerechte
personalbemessung instrument einsetzen
dies ist auch übrigens an die linke auch
orientiert die man sieht auch wie
wichtig das für die linke ist diese
debatte sind nur vier von zehn 39
abgeordneten hier vorhanden das scheint
nur eine scheindebatte für die linke zu
sein dass es für die nicht so wichtig
ist hier auch vollständig bei ihrem
antrag auch dabei zu sein aber wir
müssen auch sehen
ja ja es ist ja schön
ja ich mache hier lieber die arbeit
anstatt zu streiken also das ist gar
nicht so schlecht erwarten sie im
krankenhaus ich war im krankenhaus
letzte woche wo waren sie ja mal streikt
das ist auch immer gut ja wir müssen
mehr ausbilden liebe kolleginnen
kollegen auf die bauern und fachkräfte
aus aller welt doch wir müssen uns auch
die frage stellen wie gut das klappt in
altenheimen krankenhäusern können
ausländische pflegekräfte diesen
notstand lindern und in dieser woche hat
der sachverständigenrat integration
migration sein jahresgutachten
veröffentlicht ein wesentlicher
botschaft dieser dieses gutachtens war
dass fachkräfte mit
zuwanderungsgeschichte einen
unverzichtbaren beitrag zur
gesundheitsversorgung leistung noch an
diese menschen müssen wir denken und
danke sagen und
wir müssen erkennen zur leidwesen der
afg hierzu rechten deutschland ist ein
einwanderungsland und das ist auch gut
so meine damen und herren
aber damit weiterhin die attraktivität
für fachkräfte bleiben sollen
bürokratische hürden bei der anerkennung
von bildungs und berufsabschlüssen aus
dem abt aus dem ausland abgesenkt und
vor allem verfahren beschleunigt werden
wie es übrigens auch im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart ist ja
zusätzlich und das ist vielleicht
einfach mal wichtig dass hierzu wissen
wird vom bundesagentur für arbeit oder
deutschen gesellschaft für
internationale zusammenarbeit gtz seit
2013 das programm für ihn setzt sie um
und sie dient der anwerbung von
ausländischen pflegekräften und hier
sind viele pflege partnerländer wichtig
hier auch aus europa oder aus asien aus
afrika aber eins muss man hier klar
sagen das programm verpflichtet sich
nach den grundsätzen der fähren
migration und den richtlinien der
gesundheit weltgesundheitsorganisation
die partnerländer müsse mit der
rekrutierung einverstanden sein sonst
sie darf dort selbst nicht zu einem
mangel der pflegepersonal bestehen
feierte kolleginnen kollegen von der
linke alle drei koalitionspartner haben
sich in ihrem bundestagswahlprogramm
für eine bedarfsgerechte
personalbemessung ausgesprochen sie
steht so im koalitionsvertrag
sie steht in dem vorhaben des bmg es für
2022 wie werden sie gemeinsam mit
unserem gesundheitsminister lauterbach
umsetzen und ich finde es gut an dieser
stelle auch die kritik die geäußert ich
finde es los und dass wir ein
bundesgesundheitsminister gibt er sich
nicht nur verbal für die pflege einsetzt
sondern auch handelt erst mann aus der
praxis erkennt die probleme der
pflegekräfte und wir werden die
überweisung in den ausschuss zustimmen
aber am ende
ihre anleger natürlich abgelegt
herzlichen dank
andre ullmann war das wurde hier auch
auf die zeit hingewiesen und das auch
noch mal zur erklärung die
bundestagsabgeordneten wollen ja
eigentlich darauf achten dass es nicht
so zu lange nachtsitzungen kommt bisher
wird der heutige tag bis nach ein uhr
nachts dauern nach der aktuellen
tagesordnung
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
entschuldigung verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen 200 zwei jahre nach der geburt
der britischen krankenschwester florence
nightingale der kollege felipe hat es
vorhin gesagt eine pionierin der
modernen krankenpflege jetzt sich am
heutigen 12 bei der takte pflegenden ein
tag an dem wir die arbeit der
menschenwürdigen die kranke und alte
hingebungsvoll pflegen aber und dass er
hier explizit betont pflegekräfte
leisten nicht nur am heutigen tag
sondern jeden tag großartiges in einer
alten
in einer alternden gesellschaft wie der
unsrigen kennt mittlerweile jede und
jeder von uns eine person im familien
oder freundeskreis die pflegt oder
gepflegt werden muss dabei sind die
tätigkeiten der pflegekräfte sehr
unterschiedlich sie unterstützen beim
anziehen oder waschen beim essen sie
verabreichen medikamente messen den
blutdruck wechsel verbände oder leisten
intensivmedizinische betreuung im zuge
der korona pandemie und der damit
verbundenen überlastung des
gesundheitssystems waren pflegekräfte
nicht nur einem erhöhten
ansteckungsrisiko sondern auch erhöhten
körperlichen und psychischen
arbeitsdruck ausgesetzt die pandemie hat
uns eindringlich vor augen geführt was
pflegekräfte in unseren krankenhäusern
und pflegeeinrichtungen leisten sie
waren und sind die kritische
infrastruktur die unser land am laufen
gehalten hat und dafür gebührt ihnen
respekt und anerkennung
pferde kollegen und kollegen als
fortschritts koalition bekennen wir uns
zu dieser herausragenden leistung und
beraten zur zeit des corona pflege bonus
gesetz für pflegekräfte mit diesem
ersten baustein lösen wir das
versprechen ein dass wir mit dem
koalitionsvertrag gegeben haben und
werden kommende woche in pflege bonus
mit einem volumen von 1000 millionen
euro abschließend beraten
dabei werden wir es aber nicht belassen
wir wollen mehr fortschritt wagen und
mit voller kraft gute pflege zu einem
integralen bestandteil unserer
gesundheitspolitik machen
der angespannten situation in der pflege
werden wir mit maßnahmen begegnen die
spürbar die arbeitsbedingungen
verbessern so wollen wir in der
stationären langzeitpflege die löhne
anhebung geheizt lücken zu schließen wir
wollen den pflegeberuf attraktiver
machen ich zitiere aus unserer
koalitionsvereinbarung mit
steuerbefreiung von zuschlägen durch die
abschaffung geteilte dienste durch die
einführung träger eigener springer pools
sowie einem anspruch auf
familienfreundliche arbeitszeiten für
menschen mit betreuungs wichtigen
kindern
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen seit
meiner zeit als arzt am braunschweiger
klinikum weiß ich dass gute pflege zeit
braucht zeit um qualitätsvolle
versorgung und würdevolle pflege zu
gewährleisten
zeit für die patientinnen und patienten
mehr zeit kann es allerdings nur mit
mehr pflegepersonal
inzwischen haben die sorge nein danke
hierbei sind klar definierte
rahmenbedingungen der personalbemessung
über die pflegepersonal untergrenze
hinaus essenziell wenn wir diesem
anspruch gerecht werden wollen
vor genau diesem hintergrund werden wir
den flickenteppich unterschiedlicher
personalschlüssel durch ein
einheitliches wissenschaftlich basiertes
personalbemessung instrument in allen
pflegebereichen ersetzen
verehrte kollegin kollegen wir wollen
alles daran setzen den pflegeberuf
attraktiv und zukunftsorientiert zu
gestalten und dadurch gute pflege
ermöglichen dabei bauen wir auch auf
einen konstruktiven dialog mit der
opposition
die instrumentalisierung allerdings des
heutigen tages der pflegenden mit dem
hier vorliegenden schaufensterantrag
stellen allerdings keine grundlage für
einen konstruktiven dialog da in
aktionismus und gute pflege verehrte
kollegin und kollegen von der
linkspartei vertragen sich schlichtweg
nicht unser gemeinsames ziel ist und
bleibt ein nachhaltiges
personalbemessung instrument das den
immensen herausforderungen der pflege
entgegen wirkt daher werden wir uns
unseren fokus auf gute
arbeitsbedingungen eine exzellente
versorgung legen das ist und bleibt
unser anspruch an einer gesellschaft des
respekts und respekt und anerkennung
haben den fliegenden nicht nur am
heutigen tag verdient herzlichen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
herr kollege
war das jetzt
aber sitzt im gesundheitsausschuss für
die unionsfraktion
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren ich bin wirklich sparen sowie
haben brauchen
[Applaus]
sie eine zwischenfrage des kollegs
sommer geht bevor sie die rede begonnen
sc schlussmann wird cdu das sagen nein
glaube ich nicht
möchten diese guten tradition heute
bleiben
so sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich glaube die situation ist sehr ernst
und die anträge die heute kommen sieht
es nicht das schaufenster anträge und
ich glaube es ist grundsätzlich immer
gut wenn wir über pflege sprechen und
wenn die pflege auf der tagesordnung
steht
und wir haben heute nicht nur den
internationalen tag der pflege sondern
wir haben auch den internationalen haupt
von ms office das uns allen glaube ich
auch sehr wichtig sein sollte
und lassen sie mich zunächst einige
worte zu diesen vorliegen anderen
gerichten die kirchen in meinen augen
sind hier nicht das problem in der
pflege sondern ein teil der lösung und
ich bin froh dass sich die kirche auch
weiterhin bei werden problemen die sie
haben sich in diesem bereich einbringen
und richtig engagiert dabei sein egal ob
caritas diakonie und
der erste antrag nimmt diejenigen indem
man die mit die besten löhne in der
pflege bezahlen um zu den beliebtesten
arbeitgeber nach gehören das gehört auch
dazu
die monats vergütungen der beschäftigten
in der alten in wir sind bereits im
einstieg über den allgemeinen medien
werten gemäß der bundesagentur für
arbeit auch das sollte man hier nicht
verschweigen
grundproblem sind nicht die kirchlichen
kommissionen oder die kirche als
arbeitgeber in der pflege an sich
sondern natürlich das damoklesschwert
der finanzierbarkeit und dass wir und
das zeigt doch auch die diskussion dass
wir zu wenig hände am beton das ist das
entscheidende
wir brauchen hier eine steigerung der
mengen weil wir sonst über attraktive
arbeitsbedingungen nicht lamentieren
brauchen es steht und fällt mit dem
menschen die wir in die pflege bringen
und das ist das entscheidende
ein flächendeckender tarifvertrag und
aktuelle verkehrslage der
pflegeversicherung könnte dazu führen
dass ohnehin höhere weniger kirchen
nicht refinanziert werden und damit
würden wir den beschäftigten und somit
auf den pflegenden mehr schaden als sie
zu unterstützen
dazu kommt neben dem gehalt gibt es
viele weitere sterben die in den blick
genommen werden können und auch müssen
die entlastung der pflegekräfte durch
entbürokratisierung und auch durch
digitalisierung ist ein ansatz bessere
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
weitere akquirierung von pflegekräften
im in- und auch im ausland bessere und
effektivere
personalplanung in den eigentlichen ja
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren das
ist richtig aber ich muss hier eine sehr
kritische fragen stellen und ich bin mir
sicher dass das hier die frage von tino
sorge auch abdeckt
pflege findet überall statt den
krankenhäusern in den
pflegeeinrichtungen in den eigenen vier
wänden durch die angehörige natürlich
auch in der ambulanten pflege alles was
dazu gehört
aber der eindruck ist schon auf da das
hier in unserem
bundesgesundheitsministerium unter der
neuen führung pflegen nicht den
stellenwert hat ihm die eigentlich
bräuchten das ist der eindruck meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren um
deshalb greife ich gerne die kernaussage
des zweiten antrags auf und ich fordere
wirklich hier dass unser
bundesgesundheitsminister die endlich
seiner groß angekündigten pflegereform
rechnung trägt und endlich auch die
eckpunkte mal veröffentlicht werden doch
angebracht meine sehr geehrten damen und
anstatt sich dem thema um zu nehmen und
mit der öffentlichkeit transparent zu
kommunizieren
lassen sie am heutigen tag der pflege
und es wäre eine ideale gelegenheit
gewesen dass man hier die
reformvorschläge auch kommuniziert das
wäre heute genau der richtige tag und
ich kann sagen ich habe größten respekt
natürlich vor der pandemie und was da
alles für aufgaben sind vollkommen
glauben dass man hier kapazitäten auch
in anspruch nehmen muss ist mir auch
vollkommen klar aber ich sage schon in
aller deutlichkeit wir brauchen nicht
nur einen koroma minister sondern wir
brauchen einen gesundheits und träge
minister darf sich doch nur wo liegt
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren und
das hauptwerk ball nicht
und
ich möchte hier um etwas bitten
wir brauchen hier neue wege verbrauchen
vorschläge und die frage mich schon
jetzt sind viele ärzte hier erfahren
pult gestanden warum reformieren wir
diesen bereich des medizinstudiums nicht
wo man nicht sagen ja eingeatmet startet
hier wenn man einen medizinischen beruf
ergreifen möchte dass man ein jahr der
pflege verpflichten einführt und ich
glaube das wird es sehr viel bringen
dass junge ärzte die hier anfangen dem
beruf zu studieren dass man mit der
pflege beginnt weil man war natürlich
auch das gespielt was pflege leisten
kann was pflege auch kaum wie wichtig
pflege ist und dass wenn dann die
mediziner in den krankenhäusern sind
dass das auch das zusammenspiel die
menschlichkeit untereinander das was
natürlich viel bringen würde da bin ich
mir sicher und ich glaube auch dass wir
hier in diesem bereich natürlich luft
hätten wir würden auch durch die menge
an neuen medizinstudenten um sein stück
weit hier mit sicherheit auch verbessern
das könnte ich mir vorstellen für neue
ideen in einem mitbewerber sind wieses
union bereit und ich bitte sie diesen
dialog bildung zu führen vielen dank
herr kollege jetzt noch elf treffer war
das für die unionsfraktion und wir
merken es in der debatte dem
gesundheitspolitischen sprecher der
unions-fraktion tino sorge dem fell das
wohl doch etwas schwerer dass er hier
von seiner fraktion keine redezeit
bekommen hat versucht hier häufiger
zwischen fragen zu stellen und sich so
andere debatte auch aktiv zu beteiligen
saskia weishaupt jetzt für bündnis 90
die grünen hat mittlerweile oft das bild
der schaft in burnout klägerin im kopf
ich habe mich an diesem bild immer etwas
gestört aber nicht weil es die falsche
realität des arbeitsalltages ist der
klägerin sondern im gegenteil der beruf
bietet doch so viel mehr pflege
erfordert anspruchvolles fachwissen und
dessen anwendung in unzähligen
situationen und liebe kolleginnen das
ist auch pflege
unserer gesellschaft verlangt nicht nur
nach mehr pflegekräfte sondern die
versorgung wird auch immer komplexer die
steigende anzahl an multimorbiden und
chronisch erkrankten verlangt den
professionell pflegenden immer mehr ab
deshalb brauchen wir die
pflegewissenschaften um müssen unser
handeln und nach ihren erkenntnissen
ausrichten um den alle gerecht zu werden
schon 20 12 ich habe damals meinen
führerschein gemacht ist schon ein paar
jahre her hat der wissenschaftsrat
bereits eine quote von etwa 10 bis 20 an
akademischen pflegekräfte empfohlen zehn
jahre später also heute sind wir von
dieser zielmarke noch weit entfernt und
obwohl wird dadurch wissen dass die
komplikationsrate und die sterblichkeit
sinkt deshalb ist es für uns als
koalition sowie wir müssen akademie
sierte pflegekräfte mit ihrem fachwissen
und ihrer ganzen expertise in die
pflegerische versorgung praxis endlich
mit einbeziehung
und wer sind pflege studium erfolgreich
abschließt der verbinde die zeit
zwischen theorie und praxis
nur so können die pflege den hoch
komplexen aufgaben in zukunft auch
wirklich gerecht werden und letztendlich
ist es doch egal auch in welchem
berufsfeld geschaut das ist ganz wichtig
die möglichkeit zur fachlichen
weiterentwicklung shops zufriedenheit
und fördern letztlich den verbleib und
dem beruf und das ist ein hebel zu
fachkräftemangel in der pflege
tatsächlich und nicht irgendwelche
pflegeassistenz beruft jetzt noch
auszuweiten wir brauchen fachkräfte in
der pflege sie sind besonders wichtig
und sie sind die zukunft und deshalb
wichtig dass wir zusammen mit den
ländern tatsächlich die akademischen
pflegeausbildung endlich stärken
und da müssen wir auch selbstkritisch
sein wir müssen der pflegewissenschaft
mehr platz in den politischen
diskussionen endlich einräumen denn sie
haben doch die antworten auf die
drängenden probleme
pflegende wollen und sie sollten auch an
der ausgestaltung der pflege mit
entscheiden und deshalb hat es mich
besonders gefreut dass seit anfang
letzten jahres erstmals eine
pflegewissenschaftlerin im
wissenschaftsrat der bundesregierung
sitzt aber ehrlich gesagt dabei können
es nicht belassen auch mit der ddr
reform möchten wir der pflege endlich
mehr verantworten einräumen und ich kann
mich da nur kolleginnen und vor rebellen
anschließen wir müssen aufhören immer
über die pflege zu reden wir müssen
anfangen mit der pflege zu reden und das
auch tatsächlich endlich dezent gehen
ich weiß auch
noch zu reden diese debatte geht hier
keine gute spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und sehr
geehrte damen und herren lassen sie mich
eines vorweg sagen weil der kollege
wilstorfer angesprochen hat dass das
ministerium wolle die pflege nicht
ausreichend im blick hat ich bin mir
ganz sicher der minister und das
ministerium hat das und das heute unter
anderen der minister bei dieser debatte
nicht hier ist nicht da dass der
minister und ich glaube das ist auch
ganz gut so wie alle anderen
ministerinnen und minister auch nicht
festlegt wann wir im bundestag welche
debatten zu führen habe und dass er
heute mit dem pflege netzwerk
deutschland denjenigen die es geht rede
und antwort steht und dort jetzt gerade
ist und das halte ich durchaus auch er
hatte sich die radler
wahrscheinlich ein zweites vorab sagen
ich möchte den kollegen dr ganz herzlich
danken dass er die frage mit
ausländischen pflegefachkräften richtig
gestellt hat gerade gerückt hat und auch
unser äußerst sensibles vorgehen der
angelegenheit und ich kann nur sagen mit
meinem menschenbild verträgt es sich
nicht wenn jeder form gesprochen wird
man bediene sich bei ausländischen
pflegekräften beim menschen bedient man
sich nicht und natürlich auch nicht bei
ausländischen pflegefachkräften das ist
das was wir von der rechten seite gesagt
wurde das ist ein menschenbild das ich
absolut daneben findet das große treffen
aber auch vielleicht anders als mein
kollege vorher der linksfraktion danken
dafür dass sie die anträge vorgelegt hat
der gibt uns die möglichkeit am tag der
pflege ausführlich über pflege zu reden
und ich hoffe sie see bis nach dass man
auch ein bisschen von ihren anträgen ab
wie war da ja durchaus auch bestandteil
vieler reden und mir persönlich gibt es
die möglichkeit auch noch mal auf eine
gruppe aufmerksam zu machen die bei
diesen beiden anträgen tatsächlich nicht
erfasst ist und das liegt auch daran
dass wir dort allerdings eine personal
richtlinie haben auch wenn die aus
meiner sicht durchaus
verbesserungswürdig ist das ist damit
der bereich der pflegekräfte in der
psychiatrie überall dort wo psychiatrie
und psychosomatik draufsteht
hat mit der psyche ev schon etwas was
sozusagen eine grundlage war das hätten
sich andere lange abgucken können und
glücklicherweise nein ich
glücklicherweise gezielt ist es uns
gelungen in der letzten legislatur zu
verhindern dass die psyche pv ersatzlos
ausläuft und wir haben sichergestellt
dass es eine nachfolgeregelung gibt ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass ministerium
wetter als die vorlage ein bisschen
anders reagiert und ein bisschen
deutlicher drauf geguckt dass man da was
verbessern kann aber da bin ich guter
hoffnung dass das beim ministerium jetzt
auch in den blick kommt denn eins ist
klar personalverordnung alleine reicht
nicht sie muss auch gut und zielführend
sein und das für die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter und für den bereich sie
darf nicht am ende dadurch dass sie zu
unflexibel ist zum beispiel strukturen
gefährden oder zerstören
und insofern kann ich an dieser stelle
nun noch einmal und für meine fraktion
ausdrücklich klar sein wir sind sehr
dafür dass wir in allen bereichen klare
pflegepersonal ordnung wirtschaft und
deswegen allen bereichen auch eine
entlastung durch entsprechendes ordnung
und schaffen für die pflegefachkräfte
aber natürlich und da bin ich der
kollegin von den grünen dankbar auch für
die anderen mitarbeitenden in der pflege
die genauso verdient vernünftig
behandelt zu werden wir genauso verdient
haben eine eine ordentliche
personalverordnung zu finden und da
komme ich nochmal zur psychiatrie da ist
bei den psychotherapeuten therapeuten
durchaus auch noch was zu tun in dieser
pflege in dieser ordnung oder
kreatives kommt meine zeit läuft ab
kollege sorger leider keine
zwischenfrage geschlecht konnte ich zwar
länger aber das kommt aber gleich bleibt
last but not least will ich eins noch
kurz sagen weil ich aus
nordrhein-westfalen komme wie die
kolleginnen auch die da in münster war
die mitarbeitenden an den unikliniken
streiten zurzeit und sie streiten eben
gerade nicht für lhon fragen sie
streiken für eine entlastung story
vertrag und das ist richtig und das
müssen wir unterstützen und ich bin an
der stelle sehr sehr dankbar dass thomas
kutschaty sehr klar gesagt hat dass er
einen solchen entlastungs tarifvertrag
unterstützen wird und ich gehe davon aus
dass wir in zukunft da vielleicht auch
verbleibt dann mehr erleben werden
vielen dank
minute war das hier als letzter redner
von heute in dieser debatte zur pflege
allerdings wird uns das thema wohl noch
häufiger beschäftigen einerseits bei der
antrag der linksfraktion jetzt erst
einmal in die ausschüsse überwiesen
beraten und dann wieder ins plenum
gebracht wird und auch andererseits war
er auch von der ampel zb die
pflegepersonal regelung 2.0 die hier
auch angesprochen wurde also die methode
wie man den personalbedarf auf einzelnen
stationen der krankenhäuser ermitteln
kann ja von der ampel so vereinbart
wurde und auch irgendwann dann umgesetzt
werden soll hier im bundestag folgen
jetzt ein paar überweisung im
vereinfachten verfahren das heißt es
wird hier ohne debatte zum beispiel
abgestimmt und wir wollen diese zeit
nutzen ihn andere informationen dazu
geben aus dem nachrichtengeschehen und
das macht jetzt mein kollege im studio
hans werner fittkau